dans les trois vidéos précédentes on a
étudié la morale d'un point de vue
descriptif et prédictifs d'une certaine
manière on étudiait la morale naturelle
ou du moins la morale sélectionnée par
la sélection naturelle
mais on a aussi vu que cette morale
était loin d'être clairement la bonne
morale on a vu notamment qu'elle nous
poussait à l'hooliganisme politique et
donc à la confrontation entre groupes
rivaux et je ne vous parle pas du fait
que les moral de nos ancêtres à coups de
torture d'esclavagé de lutte des classes
sont loin de faire consensus
aujourd'hui bref on a étudié ce que la
morale et est du coup maintenant vous
devriez avoir envie de savoir ce que la
morale devrait être eh bien c'est ce
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on va étudier
la morale dit prescriptive qu'on appelle
aussi normative et pour bien en parler
j'ai invité un philosophe que j'adore
tivo de la chaîne de sophie salut c'est
un plaisir d'être ici pour parler de
morale celle thibault allez vas-y fais
nous la morale on a tendance à penser la
morale comme un ensemble de principes
formulés à l'impératif par exemple la
fameuse règle d'or ne fais pas à autrui
ce que tu ne voudrais pas qu'on te fasse
c'est ce qu'on appelle une approche
déontologiques en ceci que la valeur
morale d'une action dépendra de sa
conformité à un ensemble de règles
morales et peu importe ses conséquences
être moral c'est avoir des principes et
s'y tenir
cette approche notamment celle du grand
philosophe emmanuel kant selon quand il
existe deux types d' impératifs moraux
des impératifs hypothétique et les
impératifs catégoriques les impératifs
hypothétique sont de forme
si tu veux y alors tu dois faire x donc
l'impératif tu dois x ne vaut que comme
un moyen de réaliser cette fin y
or pour quand les impératifs moraux doit
valoir absolument
donc ils doivent être formulée sans
conditions hypothétique et s'appliquer à
tous ce sont des impératifs catégoriques
ils sont de forme tu dois x tu le dois
tout court est ce tu dois vaut pour tous
et dans tous les cas et quand défend
ardemment l'existence d'impératif
catégorique il amène même au delà de ce
que la plupart d'entre nous considèrent
aurait acceptable oui quand tu es
vraiment à cheval sur ces impératifs
convaincu que dire la vérité est un
impératif absolu quand soutenait que
même à des assassins poursuivant un ami
qui se serait réfugiée chez vous on
aurait le devoir de dire la vérité
oui quand et moralement hardcore quand
il a un principe ici tient et à écouter
certains militants politiques ce n'est
pas le seul
nombreux textes de loi ou speech
politique sous entendent souvent
l'existence de principes moraux qui
selon eux serait universelle où
devraient être universels
on parle typiquement de libertés
fondamentales de droits fondamentaux de
devoirs fondamentaux et on retrouve
aussi des principes déontologiques dans
les fameuses trois lois de la robotique
introduite par isaac asimov loi numéro
un robot ne peut porter atteinte à un
être humain ni en restant passif
permettre qu'un être humain soit exposé
au danger loi numéro 2 un robot doit
obéir aux ordres donnés par un être
humain sauf si de tels ordres entrent en
conflit avec la première loi loi numéro
3 un robot doit protéger son existence
tant que cette protection n'entre pas en
conflit avec la première ou la deuxième
loi alors ces trois lois elles peuvent
paraître sens et raisonnable sauf que
les romands d'asimov montre justement
que ces trois lois échoue à saisir le
comportement moral que l'on veut
vraiment a signé au robot en fait
construire une morale déontologique
satisfaisante
c'est super galère et si vous voulez
l'avis d'un expert en intelligence
artificielle je vous conseille cette
superbe vidéo de computer file mais la
difficulté à déterminer des impératifs
catégoriques adéquat qui font que nous
serons su ce n'est pas la seule
difficulté de la proche des routes aux
logiques de la morale un système
biologique étant essentiellement un
ensemble de règles soit une action est
fait en conformité avec ces règles
et alors elle est bonne sinon elle est
mauvaise or en pratique il peut arriver
qu aucune action possible
pas même l'inaction ne satisfasse toutes
les règles morales et ça on n'en parle
plus longuement dans la vidéo chez
monsieur fille que faire quand toutes
les actions possibles sont mauvaises bah
il faudra faire l'action la moins
mauvaise
et donc on voudrait une théorie qui
permettent de hiérarchiser les valeurs
des actions d'une façon plus fine que
juste bien et mal et ce à une approche
purement déontologiques en général ne le
permet pas en somme un simple ensemble
de règles fixant absolument ce qui est
beau ou mauvais ça ne semble pas
suffisant à nous aider à agir moralement
par opposition à la proche des
ontologies qu en théorie des jeux on va
souvent préféré une approche
utilitariste en gros l'utilitarisme
consiste à poser non pas des principes
mais un objectif à la morale et cet
objectif ce sera la maximisation du
bonheur général aux une situation donnée
donc envisager toutes les actions
possibles associés à chacune d'elles
l'effet attendu qu'elle aura sur le
bonheur
des individus et choisissez celles dont
l'effet attendu et le plus positif ou le
moins négatif et bien souvent quand on
cherche à justifier une approche
déontologique montenvers l'utilitarisme
du genre pugnière c'est bien parce que
ça donne davantage d'une scène telus à
coopérer ce qui sera alors bénéfique
pour tous
ce qui revient à dire que les impératifs
catégoriques de forme tu dois faire x
sont en fait implicitement des
impératifs hypothétique de forme si tu
veut maximiser le bonheur général
alors tu dois faire x alors il y aurait
beaucoup beaucoup à dire sur les kits à
rythmes et ses variantes est d'ailleurs
sur scène ce forum on a parlé de comment
inclure des notions comme l'équité ou la
méritocratie mais pour aujourd'hui
j'aimerais insister sur un aspect très
contre intuitif de l'utilitarisme qui je
pense gagnerait beaucoup à être mieux
compris la franche déontologique suppose
que les devoirs moraux sont absolus donc
ils s'imposent à tous dans tous les cas
si dire la vérité est un devoir absolu
comme le penser quand alors il faut
toujours et à tous dire la vérité peu
importe les préférences de ceux qui
seront touchés par votre action un
utilitarisme au contraire s'il veut
moralement bien agi hier devra
s'informer et tenir compte des
préférences des autres pour être
toujours mieux capables de maximiser
leur bonheur donc évidemment un
utilitariste considérera qu'il a le
devoir de mentir à des assassins qui
cherche un ami caché chez lui mais cela
va plus loin
si un utilitariste a des raisons de
penser que vous préférez ne pas entendre
la vérité sur un certains sujets il aura
le devoir de respecter cette préférence
en vous ment temps pourvu évidemment que
ce mensonge n'est pas par ailleurs
d'autres conséquences plus mauvaise et
en particulier pour savoir s'il a le
devoir moral de mentir lüthi cariste
aura au préalable le devoir moral de
comprendre les préférences des autres et
ça ça commence par absolument arrêter
les phrases du genre je comprends pas
comment on peut croire que blablabla
si vous ne comprenez pas pourquoi les
autres croient ce qu'il croit ce n'est
pas leur faute mais bien votre faute
et puis l'utilitarisme doit garder en
tête que s'agissant du bonheur des
autres ce sont les préférences des
autres qui importe si l'autre est outrée
par la terminologie pains au chocolat
alors l'utilitarisme aura le devoir
moral de l'éviter autant que possible en
présence de l'autre même s'il est sûr et
certain que la page wikipedia s'intitule
bel et bien d'un chocolat l'important
n'est pas d'avoir raison
l'important est de main
si mise et le bonheur général en
particulier l'utilitarisme va chercher à
bannir des phrases du genre - samouraï
pas vexer moi je vois pas fait comme ça
il ne faut pas faire aux autres ce qu'on
ne veut pas qu'ils nous fassent en effet
cette règle d'or qui est pourtant se
voient reconnus comme la règle morale la
plus importante semble fondamentalement
contraire à l'utilitarisme et à bien y
réfléchir sa critique semble assez
profondes pour quelles raisons en
traitant autrui comme il me plairait
d'être traités moi je ferai quelque
chose de bien je ferai son bonheur cela
semble présupposé que autrui aura
toujours les mêmes préférences que moi
mais rien n'est moins sûr ne serait-il
pas réellement meilleur de dire en
utilitariste ne fais pas aux autres ce
que les autres ne veulent pas qu'on leur
fasse puisque ce qui importe ce n'est
pas ce que vous auriez ressenti à la
place d'un autre mais bel et bien ce que
l'autre a ressenti lorsqu'on lui a dit
ce qu'on lui a dit et c'est pas facile
car ça va contre la tendance que nous
avons à comprendre l'esprit des autres
en supposant qu'il fonctionne comme le
nôtre ce qui n'est pertinent que jusqu'à
un certain point en sciences cognitives
on parle de théorie de l'esprit
et s'il y a bien une chose qu'il faut
retenir de la théorie des jeux c'est
bien l'importance de toujours se
demander ce que les autres pensent et
veulent notamment pour prédire l'issue
des interactions humaines ou si on et
utilitariste pour maximiser le bonheur
du plus grand nombre
alors tout ça ça ne veut pas dire non
plus que l'utilitaire east ne va jamais
forcer quelqu'un à faire quelque chose
dans certains contextes utilitariste
peut avoir le devoir moral de agir de
manière autoritaire en fait
l'utilitarisme tu ne donnes pas une
valeur absolue à la liberté à l'égalité
ni même à la vérité d'une preuve
mathématique ou plutôt pour l'utilitaire
east ce qui importe c'est ce que l'autre
pense de la liberté de l'égalité ou de
la preuve mathématique si l'autre
n'attache aucune importance à sa liberté
peut-être parce qu'ils pensent que le
libre arbitre n'est qu'une illusion
et s'il utilitariste est persuadé que
l'autre finira par être heureux si on le
force à écouter le podcast actions par
exemple alors l'utilitarisme n'aura
aucun problème à force et l'autre à
écouter le podcast actions de façon
générale 6,1 utilitariste est convaincu
que en vous forçant à faire x vous serez
plus heureux que si on vous laisse la
liberté de faire x ou alors ce serait
pour lui
man immoral de vous laisser la liberté
de faire x et ça peut sembler choquant
dit comme ça mais en fait c'est ce qu'on
fait tous quand on éduque des enfants il
semble raisonnable par exemple d'obliger
les enfants à aller à l'école parce
qu'on pense qu'en fin de compte ils
seront plus heureux ainsi que si on les
avait laissés totalement libres d'y
aller ou non de même l'utilité ariste
est prêt à sacrifier la liberté de se
vacciner
voire même l'exigence démocratique selon
laquelle il faut qu'une majorité du
peuple veuille imposer la vaccination à
tous styles et sur des bienfaits de la
vaccination
et s'ils pensent que c'est bien fait
apporteront plus de bonheur que le
sentiment de liberté à choisir ou à
refuser de se vacciner et que la
possible frustration à devoir subir une
loi antidémocratique l'utilitarisme ne
reconnaît pas la liberté l'égalité la
vérité comme des valeurs absolues
sacrifier tout ça peut être moralement
nécessaire s'il en résulte une
maximisation du bonheur et c'est
d'ailleurs en réponse un devoir moral
utilitariste que j'ai choisi de censurer
les commentaires que je juge néfaste au
bonheur global ceci dit en fait la
plupart des utilitaires east à cordes
quand même beaucoup d'importance au
respect des libertés individuelles
et c'est parce qu'il considère que
arrivé à sa majorité chacun est le
meilleur juge de ce qui peut faire son
bonheur on en revient ainsi à l'idée
qu'il faut faire le bonheur des
individus tels que l'individu le
conçoivent et non d'après l'idée
personnelle que vous faites du bonheur
en fait être beau et qu'il cariste c'est
incroyablement difficile puisque ceci
nécessite de comprendre tous les
mécanismes sociétaux qui permettent aux
individus de vivre tel qu'ils vivent et
d'accéder aux biens dont ils disposent
ça passe par comprendre l'origine et la
production des biens comme des vestes en
laine l'origine et l'importance des
ressources naturelles ou encore
l'origine et la création de l'argent or
les moyens de production d'une veste de
laine l'exploitation des ressources
naturelles et le rôle de l'argent ainsi
que toutes les notions qu'on a vu dans
cette série comme les incentives
l'hooliganisme où le capital moral sont
des notions très contre intuitive et
souvent très mal comprise un
utilitariste qui ignorent cela sera
nécessairement un très mauvais
utilitariste pour un utilitariste il
s'agit dès lors d'un devoir moral que de
comprendre autant que possible les
sciences sociales pour ensuite
déterminer
quelles actions permettront le bonheur
du plus grand nombre il s'agit d'une
condition nécessaire à l'utilitarisme
mai et ça le théoricien des jeux en
moins adore il s'agit aussi d'une
condition suffisante
autrement dit il s'agit d'une question
scientifique que de déterminer que faire
pour répondre au devoir moral
utilitariste bref utilitariste aux une
fin qui paraît légitime le bonheur
général
et si la fin est légitime tous les
moyens pour y arriver sont bons la fin
justifie les moyens
il me semble qu'un terrain
jeu est forcément fasciné par
l'utilitarisme et qu'il a même de bonnes
chances de vouloir tendre vers cette
philosophie morale
cependant l'utilitarisme a aussi ses
limites et monsieur fille a notamment
mise à l'épreuve
mon utilité risme et je dois bien dire
que j'ai au moins quelques restes
déontologique
d'ailleurs pour conclure j'aimerais
insister sur trois difficultés majeures
de l'utilitarisme la première la notion
d'équité on l'a déjà vu dans les vidéos
21 à 23 l'équité c'est pas une notion
facile et pourtant on sent que c'est une
notion crucial qui doit être rajoutées à
l'utilitarisme une approche pour un
utilitarisme équitable est ce qu'on
appelle le max mines fairness qui
consiste à maximiser le bonheur du plus
malheureux dans un article de ma thèse
on a étudié une alternative qui consiste
à minimiser une pénalisation
exponentielle d'une forme de quantité de
jalousie notamment dans un contexte
social bon faut s'accrocher un petit peu
mais j'invite quand même les plus
motivés d'entre vous allez voir la
seconde de difficulté et la manière de
traiter le futur par opposition au
présent une façon de faire consiste à
considérer que le bonheur pendant 24
heures dans un an moins d'importance que
le bonheur dans les 24 heures qui
viennent
et ça en économie c'est typiquement
modélisé par un facteur des secondes qui
fait que l'importance du futur des croît
exponentiellement
mais ce qui rend l'utilitarisme délicat
c'est que ce facteur d ce conte priori
il est assez arbitraire et d'ailleurs
ils varient clairement d'un individu à
l'autre
enfin une troisième difficulté est que
certains principes moraux que nous avons
semble impossible à justifier à partir
de fondement utilitariste c'est le cas
notamment de la protection de la
biodiversité qui étrangement tient à
coeur à nombre d'entre nous alors que
bien souvent détruire la biodiversité
pour planter des champs est souvent une
bonne façon d'améliorer la production
agricole et donc la qualité de vie des
gens et donc d'augmenter le bonheur du
plus grand nombre et pour en savoir plus
à ce sujet je recommande la superbe
vidéo de dirt cheap et le qui est aussi
le premier épisode du podcast axiome
qu'on a lancé avec monsieur fille et je
vous invite encore une fois allé voir la
vidéo qu'on a fait sur sa chaîne où il
me met un peu mal à l'aise avec des
expériences de pensée qui met à
l'épreuve
l'utilitarisme
justement comme vous l'aurez compris je
l'espère show un énorme fan de ne se
fier de tout ce qui fait notamment sur
sa chaîne où il ya énormément de vidéos
qui sont vachement matheuse qui sont
carrément des vidéos que j'aurais pu
avoir fait sur scène soit roll si
j'avais eu le temps et l'intelligence
j'avais notamment prévu de parler d'
adam smith dans cette série et sur ses
paroles soient démocratie mais
finalement comme il l'avait déjà fait et
il avait tellement bien fait que ben je
vous conseille vraiment d'aller voir et
de voir ça comme un complément à cette
série sur la démocratie
mais il ya aussi des vidéos beaucoup
plus matheuse est super intéressante
notamment souvent proche de la logique
et je recommande là pour le coup
fortement ses vidéos sur les lois de
bise ou encore sa vidéo sur le paradoxe
du condamné que bruce d'y penser avait
présenté mais des explications
additionnelles de monsieur prix sont
vraiment vraiment génial et parle
vraiment d'un problème au coeur des
fondements de la logique donc je
conseille vraiment vivement vivement sa
chaîne et je recommande également
vivement le podcast qu'on a lancées
ensemble
axiome l'idée du peu cassé c'est qu'on
parle de façon beaucoup plus informelle
donc du coup c'est aussi plus long mais
du coup je vous invite vraiment
activement écouter ça je sais pas
pendant il transporte quelque chose
comme ça sachant qu'il ya pas grand
chose à l'image c'est surtout le son qui
compte
vous pouvez écouter ça en voiture dans
les transports que sais-je encore les
harfangs n'a parlé de sélection de
groupes et notamment le fait que la
sélection naturelle a sélectionné
l'organisme politiques et notamment
j'avais fini à la vidéo avec une
citation de la marseillaise dont le
dernier vers 2 du refrain de la
marseillaise qui car sang impur abreuve
nos sillons et vous avez été très
nombreux à commenter et affirmé que le
sang impur de cette expression ne
correspondait pas au sens et demi ce qui
d'ailleurs intuitivement par un petit
peu bizarre quand vous y réfléchissez
mais surtout je vous recommande de
l'excellente page wikipédia à ce sujet
qui discute très bien de la controverse
autour de l'interprétation de ce dernier
vers notamment l'interprétation comme
quoi ce sang impur ce sera le sang des
citoyens même français du peuple
français
c'est une théorie extrêmement récente
qui semble complètement incompatible
avec l'utilisation du mot sang impur à
l'époque du coup sa tendance à être
plutôt rejetée par les historiens et
honnêtement ça sent un petit peu
ligue à nice mme patriotique que
d'essayer de réinterpréter le dernier
verre de nîmes national français est du
reste lorsque vous voyez les citations
qui ont été relevés par aymeric du
caennaise vous voyez que la manière dont
les gens parlaient pendant la révolution
française a été vachement hooligans
patriotes mais à la limite tout ça on
s'en fout complètement
ce qui compte en terme d'urbanisme
politiques notamment de l'organisme
politique qui sort de nous lorsqu'on est
marseillaise c'est plus le sens qu'on
donne marseillaise aujourd'hui est ce
que cette marseillaise suggère pour nous
et j'ai bien l'impression qu'avec une
dernière phrase comme ça elle fait
largement sortir le hooliganisme
patriotique franco-français en nous en
particulier si j'ai mis un what the fuck
à la fin de la vidéo précédente s'est
poursuivie nier la réaction de quelqu'un
qui découvriraient l'hymne français et
qu'il interprèterait littéralement ça
paraît quand même vachement violent
aeternam david chemla et etienne vers
parent demande si le hooliganisme avait
finalement une si mauvaise chose
ça permet la survie de nos groupes
notamment or il faut faire gaffe la
vidéo précédente était purement
descriptive c'est le but c'était de
décrire la morale naturelle qui
surgissait en nous après ça peut être
bien ou mal moi j'ai tendance à être
assez utilitarisme donc pour moi ce qui
importe c'est le bonheur général et du
coup le giga nisme poétique et bien si
et seulement si j'ai envie de dire il
favorise le bonheur globale en
particulier si je prends un point de vue
assez qui charisme sur la question de
hesc d'hooliganisme petit que c'est bien
ou mal je veux vraiment envie d'insister
sur le fait que ce soit bien ou mal
n'est pas une règles déontologiques
fondamentales ce qui importe ce sont les
conséquences de l'organisme politique et
donc il est possible que dans beaucoup
de cas ce soit très mal et que dans
beaucoup d'autres cas il ya eu kahnisme
petit que soi très bien d'un point de
vue utilitariste en particulier c'est ça
que je trouve très intéressant avec
d'utilitarisme ça évite de se poser des
fausses questions du genre est ce que ça
s'est bien mal se passer
qu'importe ce qui importe c'est quelles
sont les conséquences de 6,1 et les
conséquences de ci ou ça dépend de
notamment du contexte socio économique
dans lequel on se pose ces questions
donc il ya peut-être dû 2
ganis mon petit qui va dans ce sens mais
j'ai quand même l'impression que la
plupart du temps quand on est vraiment
hooligans c'est à dire lorsqu'on est
prêt à défendre de façon irrationnelle
et sans remettre en question ce que l'on
pense j'ai quand même vachement
l'impression que ça empêche d'avoir une
phase de réflexion qui pourrait par
exemple mené à l'utilitarisme notamment
se demander quels sont les préférences
des autres personnes
j'ai l'impression que lui ligue à nice
mme est un frein qui a tendance à plutôt
empêcher une réflexion sur ce que
l'autre pense du coup ça va à l'encontre
j'ai l'impression avec un pire souvent
de l'utilitarisme bon après
l'utilitarisme c'est une philosophie
morale normative qui a beaucoup de
qualités
je pense mais pour le coup c'est quelque
chose de complètement débat table savoir
si c'est vraiment bien ou mal
et de souhaiter le bonheur général et
notamment il ya peut-être des trucs qui
sont plus importants que le bonheur
général on parle notamment dans le
podcast actionne avec ses filles bref
j'aurais tendance à dire que la défense
de nos groupes et pas forcément une
mauvaise chose ça ça peut rapporter plus
de bonheur que de malheur mais
l'hooliganisme qui ressort le fait de
défendre irrationnellement notre groupe
est quelque chose de trop récurrent je
trouve et gagnerait pour l'utilitarisme
réduire notre organisme poétique et à
partir de meilleur fondement pour
construire notre droite le titre harris
mettant une alternative en tout cas un
premier jet qui je pense est intéressant
et j'espère que j'aurai aimé cette vidéo
qui vous allez penser aux fondements de
votre philosophie morale notamment c'est
un effort à saintes à 100 de chercher à
la décrire de la plus simplement
possible plutôt que chercher à avoir un
avis moral sur des questions assez
différente mais pas de façon relier
quelqu'un il risquera fortement y avoir
des inconsistances dans votre moral par
ailleurs sachez que les semaines qui
viennent les deux semaines qui viennent
il n'y aura pas d'épisode
de la série sur démocratie sur un
central tout simplement parce que je
pars en vacances et on reviendra après
mes vacances avec une vidéo sur le
travail notamment le statut du travail
quand il a évolué depuis plusieurs
siècles et notamment qu'est ce qu'il en
est aujourd'hui
quelle est la bonne façon de penser le
travail aujourd'hui et il y aura un
autre invité à mecs j'adore également
qui viendra intervenir dans la vidéo à
venir
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
liker à la commenter à la partager pense
à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les
futurs épisodes
merci aux ti peur pour leurs dons et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois l'inspiration le truc utilitariste
sérieux guitariste tarik a attiré sur le
bouton qui n'a eu un sens aucun d'eux au
curé sur les tubes à dire avec le rapid
match et pas la recherche en maths on a
juste trouvé ce qu'il fallait de maths
pour réussir à faire marcher cette
machine qui rend tout le monde heureux
on attendait en plus ce serait triste
non